there is
though potentially some areas where
there will be some consternation and
concern now that we're in this new
reality where every day we have
announcements from teams of guys who are
on the covet 19 list guys who are off
the covet 19 list and matthew stafford
the highest profile player so far to be
on the list is off the list and the
lions took great pains yesterday to
point out that matthew stafford actually
did not test positive it was a false
positive and my understanding is and
look i asked the lions and they've yet
to explain it i may get more information
today apparently they have determined it
truly was a false positive i thought
well they just assume it's a false
positive because it was sandwiched
between a bunch of negatives but it
truly was a false positive and i think
that the lions have been as aggressive
about getting this out there as they
have been because matthew stafford's
wife kelly has reacted to this very
negatively about the stigma it creates
for her kids for her that's look you
know i've said all along there should be
no stigma in being positive for covet 19
because we need the transparency we need
to know who has it it's not like it's
some
some disease like leprosy or something
that you know it's it's something that a
lot of people have and it's no less
common than the common cold but the
problem is there will be some people who
treat people who are covet positive or
who have family members who are covert
positive differently and i think that's
what kelly stafford was experiencing and
there's a balance there that the league
has to figure out how to strike you know
we we need to know what's going on and
obviously if guys aren't present if
matthew stafford isn't there on a sunday
yeah would we just chose not
in today i mean we're gonna we're gonna
be able to connect the dots so i don't
know if you can craft a perfect system
but i you know i was surprised at how
aggressive the lions were yesterday in
making that statement chris and i think
the end result was it created some
issues for the stafford family and kelly
stafford was pressing the lions to come
out and say something and she said i
blame the nfl for not holding themselves
accountable on an instagram post when it
comes to these issues about you know
making sure that there is an accurate
test and it's accurate information
that's being distributed yeah well i
mean again everybody this is it's a
moving target right now we're getting
used to all of this you know the nfl the
detroit lions the players all of that
you're right there is a stigma out there
mike i mean i went from early on during
this virus and knowing like oh our you
know we we never a work partner we know
that his wife had had the you know the
the virus there was only a few people i
knew you know that had the virus now
here as of late there's been i know a
bunch of people that have had it or a
family member had it or whatever it may
be and there is reluctance to say it at
times which you know i just do want to
echo that point too like we we can't be
that way it's okay yeah like you said
this is part of our world right now and
let's be transparent talk about it it's
gonna help ease other people's pain you
know about
thinking about it all the time what is
it gonna be like when i get it so it's
good to have that information out there
and then you know when it comes to the
detroit lions and all of that hey you
know
yeah this is something we're going to be
ready for too false positives i don't
know maybe even false negatives whatever
it is but they did the best they could
and you know mike the only thing i ask
you is like how do they know officially
that it was like officially a fault you
know i i was fine with the process i
mean listen you get you know
negative tests or positive tests and
then you have negative tests to follow
it no symptoms everything like that i
mean that's that sounds like good
protocol to me i'm just seriously asking
you like how did they actually figure it
out finally that it was a false negative
my understanding at this point is they
went back and and retested the original
material that tested
there was more of it you know i here
here's the thing it's an imperfect
process because
the nasal swab collection
has to get
material right that contains the
antibody that would show that the person
has the virus and is reacting to the
virus and uh that you know so if it
shows up positive they've got something
and i was doing some research yesterday
one of the primary bases for false
positive is you've actually got
something else you've got the common
cold or you've got some other virus that
is being mistaken for covet 19. so
that's one way to get false positives
but false positives will happen false
negatives will happen that's the flip
side of this coin that's scary falls
positive yeah false positive is you know
uh up hey and look false positive could
knock your quarterback out for the super
bowl right in theory a false positive at
the worst time
could wipe out your starting quarterback
for the biggest game of the year the
other side of the coin though with the
false negative is the reality that
if it slips through the cracks that
someone's positive who is shedding virus
and he's out on a practice field or it
happens during a game because remember
until we have point-of-care testing
the 24-hour lag is going to be there you
can have a guy who's negative negative
negative
negative on a saturday
that's a false negative he's actually
positive
and you find out the next day that he
really was positive and he's out there
in the 24 intervening hours infecting
other people that's one of the risks of
this and look even if you have point of
care testing you you yeah it's not going
to be possibility for false positives
and false negatives so now now and this
is one of the reasons why they're not
doing point of care right now point of
care accuracy 80 to 85 range it's
getting better all the time
for the test that they send away to be
analyzed in the laboratory it's 98 99
but still look at how many tests are
being done you're going to have false
positives and false negatives because of
the sheer volume of testing that the nfl
is doing this is something that we need
to be paying attention to because false
positives create problems
false negatives create problems and
ideally we want to get to the point
where you know the test gets
to the truth as to whether or not the
person has the virus yeah i mean you're
right and it's it's not going to be
perfect now the big thing is to me is
are you is everybody okay with the
process that we just saw with matt
stafford you know that's going to be
to me where like all right i know
he's got the false positive you know
sandwiched in between a bunch of
negatives and you know two negatives or
was it three negatives after the false
positive along with three you know three
right along with no symptoms or anything
like that you know if this if this
happens during the year is everybody
gonna be okay
with like okay we've given them we've
given them five tests
one came back we believe it was a false
positive but the other four are negative
and he has no symptoms and if this case
was to happen let's just say week three
on a saturday or a friday or something
like that with a guy like matt stafford
or another notable quarterback is
everybody gonna be okay that okay it's
five tests one was a false positive
everything else was negative can he play
you know that that is that's something
that i just read into yesterday like are
we gonna have some people going oh i
don't feel comfortable with it or own
the nfl and the lions let him back into
the game you know or into the locker
room too quickly
i guess that's my only question that
that arises from this whole situation
well and the one area that we have that
would provide guidance when it comes to
whether and to what extent guys will be
cleared to get back into the locker room
and back onto the field and this isn't a
perfect apples and apples comparison
chris but one of the big flaws in the
concussion protocol
you aren't going to see a key player in
a big game right get shoved into the
blue tent get escorted into the locker
room for 15 minutes of real time to
determine
whether or not no he has a concussion
because if the end result is he doesn't
you've deprived the team of his services
right while you have determined that
he's indeed okay now again it's not
apples to apples but i could see some
stuff happening behind the scenes where
there is expedited effort to test and
retest and re-test and retest and yeah
rest keep testing keep testing until
it's negative keep going test him again
it's still positive test him again it's
still positive damn it's the super bowl
test him again test him until he's
negative i i didn't see that happening
well you're right turn those machines
back on well yeah i mean you know with
your bother well nobody's gonna let you
know let their star players go down
easily you're you're right about that no
doubt but like realistically though you
know i have no problem with what we saw
there yesterday you know
or with the lions like hey it's not an
exact science right now you know this is
as good as we're gonna do in just about
any place in the world i mean the guy
got tested five times in what two days
three days what was it so you know i
mean if that's not going to make people
feel comfortable
along with doctors there
asking about his symptoms and you know
looking into other areas and talking to
him and all that then damn we're not
going to be able to make this happen
this year so i hope everybody can get
their heads around what happened with
matt stafford that it's going to happen
again most likely and that you know yes
we hope the nfl is ethical here and
teams are ethical but i hope just
players and and people and organizations
can
can
be at ease with this type of situation i
guess is what i'm saying mike
just another layer of what will be the
layer
stress
for football fans right for fans of a
team for fantasy football players you
never know which day is the day that
that key player all of a sudden isn't
available and this matthew stafford
example
is going to cause plenty of people chris
to react to the news that someone some
key player is on the covet 19 list
because of a positive test by wondering
is it a false positive test him again
yeah test him again sure keep testing
until we know that it's a false positive
or test him until it's negative test him
until we get a false negative and then
let's go play football so uh it's it's
look
the nfl already is chock full of drama
and day in and day out intrigue and this
is just another reason
to pay attention to everything that's
happening in the nfl once the games
start being played you never know
when that key player is going to pop up
and i think you're going to have extra
anxiety from fans from coaches from
executives from everyone connected to
the game directly or indirectly when we
get into
saturday morning saturday afternoon yeah
saturday evening sunday morning
when are we going to find out that
somebody turned up positive when are we
going to find out that somebody's
developing symptoms and who's not going
to be available for that game on sunday
why would you from in the states where
wagering is legal why why would you
place a bet on a game
at any point before
15 minutes prior to kickoff well i mean
you're yeah i hear you you don't know
what what what team or what players are
going to be out there and and mike just
to echo kind of what you're saying i
think that fear you're talking about
it's still there and you know with my my
friends and people i talk to in the nfl
it's still there right now you know it
is i think and you mentioned it like you
know hey college kids professionals act
like professionals can we trust the
college kids the one sentiment i keep
coming back to
with friends that i text and coaches and
people everything like that it always
comes back to
i just don't know if i trust some of
these young guys are we gonna be able to
trust these young guys on a friday night
during the season and they're not gonna
go out and do something and be around
people that is the common thread i've
heard you know i don't think anybody's
worried about the professionals like
you're talking about the guys who've
been in the league four five eight seven
ten years whatever it may be i think
it's some of those oh rookie i'm free
i'm out of college i got a little money
in my pocket i think those are the guys
that scare coaches and people in front
offices in the nfl about their teams
right now
yeah look a lot of factors a lot of
issues a lot of challenges in what will
be
arguably the strangest nfl season that
we've encountered and real question
is this the first of multiple seasons
like this i've taken a look at the final
documents that were prepared by the nfl
and the nflpa and one of the realities
they have already agreed that
that yeah if this is still hanging
around in 2021 we're just gonna use
these same procedures next year right i
think it's prudent to be ready for it
but i also think that it's practical
that until we have some sense of
confidence that they're gonna find a
magic wand that makes this all go away
and there is no magic wand we've been
dealing with it for five months now i
think it's
it's something we need to get used to
because it's not going to be
most likely a one year only thing i
think it's going to be two seasons and
hopefully it's only two seasons where
this specter of the possibly immediate
unavailability of a key player happens
any given sunday monday thursday or
playoff
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports